welcome ladies I'm Jasper McDaniel beer
pilot this is awesome
no clothes this bag looks just like mine
we have to call Jasper there is
something off the bottom I say we do one
just one you make me drop like right
where is our little Bloodhound Daisy
we're coming for you
we have to do something Simon timer we
have to call the cops come on noon bring
the product and I'll bring your friend
if we call anyone she's dead we need to
handle this wow we're going to get a
call in a minute
answer the phone
briefly what I wrote
we have what you want but we also have a
very particular set of skills skills
that make us a nightmare for people like
you let our friend go now but if you
don't who will find you and we will kill
you
[Music]
what next then all cats real she's crazy